hello back to Hannity tonight to  consider a conservative rock star group  Diamond and silk they get the final word  again what's this hey Sean here's  tonight final word well we know that  Hillary Clinton is on a book tour but we  call it a desperation tour maybe she's  trying to reinvent herself Oh Hillary  Hillary Hillary now she's out playing  the blame game fashion everyone in her  sight yeah saying woe is me well you did  it to me oh it's not my fault  where the buck stops with her and you  know what Sean she will go down as the  most clueless politician and history  yeah because she didn't know her face  and she didn't know how to stay on baby  and she's way off base even Democrats  and she will say anything to get a vote  and you know what we find in outshine  what she would say anything to sell a  book now Sean that our final word but  tonight all right are our friends  diamond and cell